Let's say you're scrolling through Facebook and oh, look, another shocking headline.
So shocking that it must be false.
But, this time, it kind of looks true.
You're not alone if you've had this dilemma.
Here's how to spot fake and misleading information online.
For posts that link to a website, first, check what the website's domain is.
.edu and .gov are generally considered to be trustworthy.
When it comes to news articles,...
...check what news outlet the information is coming from.
Is it from a well-known and trustworthy source?
If you're skeptical, the easiest thing to do is search for the same story elsewhere.
If other reputable outlets have covered it, the story is more reliable.
When vetting posts,...
...it's also important to check the date that the article or tweet was first published.
Headlines can sometimes appear to be relevant,...
...but the actual story or tweet is outdated or out of context...
...and therefore misleading.
For posts by individual users,...
...look to see if that user has a blue check mark next to their name.
The check mark means that Facebook and Twitter have verified the account...
...is run by a real person or organization that matches the username.
It's important to combine all these steps together...
...to be able to make the best judgment.
And lastly, if you're unsure about information you see on your social media,...
...at the very least, don't repost it.
Sharing information that you can't confirm is true will only make you part of the problem.